Your task is going to be to derive the reflection equation. So you're given the
V vector towards the eye, and the mirror surface is normal N. These 2 vectors
are normalized and the dot product between them is computed and stored as D.
You are now given 2 other vectors, dV which is the V vector multiplied by this
dot product and dN, the normal multiplied by this dark product. You can see how
this 2 vectors are produced here. For example DV is shown as the projection of
N on to the V vector. And DN is shown as the projection of V onto the N vector.
Here's our normalized reflection vector R, this is our goal. The question to
you is given these 4 vectors, how do we compute this normalized reflection
direction vector? You can use any and all of the four vectors in your answer
which should consist of 4 integers. These integers can be positive, negative or
0. For example, if you think the single copy of DN vector negated is the same
as the R vector, you would put 0, negative 1, 0, 0. Here's a hint. This answer
is not correct. What values form the right answer?